League of Legends is about to change
once again this week has seen the launch
of the Season 13 pre-season patch
there's a whole bunch of changes to talk
about and there's now Pokemon in the
game
kind of
you'll see what I mean
all right just before we dive into
today's video I want to remind you guys
we have a new merch line that came out
in the summer some of the items on that
new merch line were hoodies I have them
here I'm enjoying wearing them now
because it's getting a little bit colder
if that sounds ideal to you then click
on the link in the description box to go
and check out the new merch thanks I'm
sure you'll love it world is over season
12 is dead Long Live season 13 all eyes
are now on January and the launch of the
next season of League of Legends
preseason began this week which means
there's already been a whole bunch of
changes implemented for us to take a
look at the first thing Riot listed on
the patch notes was
the return of the chem Tech dragon now
for those of you who have pushed this
out of your memory the cam Tech Dragon
was released during pre-season last year
alongside the hex tech Dragon people
loved hextech they still do I personally
think that the hex tech games are some
of the coolest additions to the game in
recent years but chemtech people didn't
like that the chemtech map
transformation replaced large areas of
brushes in the jungle with a fog that
obscured those within it to everything
except control Wars problem with the
chemtech dragon is when the enemy team
is ahead you can't put defensive Wards
as the defending team you can't put
defensive Wards and you can't fight in
your own Vision when they walk in
because everyone is invisible so if I
push in midwave as the enemy team and I
stand Here in My invisibility you can't
do anything you actually come to it
also kind of sucked for Rengar Mains
only having like half the brushes they
normally do to jump out of but what
annoyed people even more than the weird
map was the chem Tech Soul chem Tech
Soul revived players for a few seconds
in a zombie form which just felt like
you had to kill the enemy twice this
clip from the time shows just how
ridiculous that was with one team having
to kill their opponents 13 times thanks
to chem Tech's soul and guardian angels
[Music]
foreign
then in January of this year Riot
u-turned and disabled the chemtech Drake
soul and terrain but implied that it
would return at some point once they got
it right well that point is now and here
are the changes killing the chemtech
dragon gives five percent tenacity and
five percent heal and shield power the
cam Tech Dragon deals a hundred percent
of its total A.D plus four percent of
the target's Health with every attack
and this part is really interesting when
it's below 50 HP it gains 33 damage
resistance and Deals 50 more damage I
kind of love this because it forces
teams to not just sit there juggling
dragon aggro with this change neither
team is going to want to be sitting
there tanking the cam take Dragon once
his health drops below 50 teams are
going to be forced to commit to securing
the dragon or fighting for it a lot
sooner than before I think that could be
really cool moving on to the map changes
they are different in a good way
although to be fair that's a pretty low
bar the idea now is that chemtech
affects the plants on the map in various
ways honey fruit will give a small
Shield to the player and not slow them
down at all could be clutch stalkers
Bloom grants a speed boost to allies
running towards the plant and reduces
any Wards revealed to one HP meanwhile
blast cones promise to blast twice as
far as before I'm not gonna lie I love
the look of all of those the previous
chemtech map felt like it was taking
something away from the game this feels
like what map augments are supposed to
be additions and as a jungler I'm kind
of looking forward to these blast cones
Landing me practically in the middle of
someone's Lane which should be fun and
speaking of jungling there are some
pretty big changes coming to the Jungle
with this pre-season patch I'm very
excited because junglers are getting
pets yeah these jungle companions are
going to replace traditional jungle
items junglers will be able to choose
between the Moss stomper Scorch claw or
Gus Walker which will all come in an egg
at the start of the game now some of you
might be thinking wait a second second
isn't this just Pokemon like actual
Pokemon well um yeah it is Pokemon I
think right are even leaning into it a
little bit The Companions will grow and
evolve throughout the game by getting
Stacks from Monster kills and Champion
takedowns their attacks will deal 20
damage plus a percentage of the
jungler's HP ad and AP they'll also heal
their owner for 70 of the damage they
deal with each attack and they'll
increase their owner's Mana regeneration
while in the jungle the companions are
gonna evolve twice in a game the first
time they evolve they'll upgrade the
jungler Smite Smite will deal 900 damage
to monsters and can be used on enemy
Champion to deal true damage to them and
slow them by 20 so that's basically like
the old Smite upgrade except it combines
chilling and challenging Smite the final
evolution is where things are going to
get interesting though first off Smite
damage will increase to 1 200 against
Monsters and deal 50 of its damage in an
AOE to other nearby monsters that is a
significant increase from the 900 damage
Smite that we're all used to there
really should be no reason junglers are
missing smites now
I'll probably still miss a few but the
final evolution will also Grant Buffs to
the jungler based on their chosen
companion these can be Shields tenacity
damage or movement speed depending on
their choice I think these are going to
be really crucial to the new gameplay
when it comes to these Buffs there's a
whole lot to unpack we're not going to
do that here but here's the gist from
what I can tell so far most dumper
sounds great for tanks Scorch claws
sounds like it's going to be the pet of
choice for Duelists and Gus Walker could
be great for anyone but I feel like
assassins might get a real kick out of
it there's also a protection buff which
everyone will get no matter what they
choose which will give junglers 30
reduced damage from Monsters as long as
two allies are nearby by nearby I don't
mean like right on top of them but just
within the facility 300 units to be
precise now I assume that this is to
make it harder to solo dragons or Barons
which
I kind of get if that's what they're
going for I think it's pretty fun to do
as a jungler in game but when it comes
to competitive play when it comes to
being a spectator it gets boring as hell
to watch people just solo those kind of
objectives I want to see Team scrap for
it so this could be cool something else
that has already got a lot of people
worked up in the preseason is Jungle
pathing on jungler's first players
they'll see recommendations for which
path to take these will be determined
using data gathered from so-called
high-skilled junglers across the globe
the past will be based on win percentage
and will be updated after each patch
yeah so a lot of people aren't happy
with this because it feels like Raya are
continuing to dumb the game down for
newer players the idea is that back in
the day junglers were rewarded for
learning buff respawn timers or learning
the best jungle path to take through
trial and error and now that's kind of
gone I hear the argument I do I do think
it's going to be a little bit
distracting at first to have that on
your mini map but I honestly think
people are going to get pretty used to
it and also hopefully Riot will
introduce a toggle on or off feature if
it gets really frustrating for people
before we leave the jungle another thing
to note is that the jungle is getting
its own mini durability update basically
camps are going to be tankier but also
hit a little softer than before they're
also going to give laners even less gold
and exp than before junglers will also
deal 20 more damage from non-true damage
sources to monsters on their side of the
Jungle but not to enemy camps now for me
this basically spells the end of counter
jungling which I think kind of sucks I
get that this is all a part of Riot
making the game more beginner friendly
but I think it was a really cool complex
part of jungling and the game in general
and I think jungling will suffer without
it right have actually insisted in the
patch notes that they're not trying to
kill counter jungling that they do want
it in the game but that right now they
feel it's just a little bit too strong
we'll have to see finally for the jungle
is sustain Riot have taken some of the
healing power outage Smite and gromp and
put it into the new Jungle companions
now Riot have said this should result in
more Champions having a healthy first
clear which should result in more
Champions being viable in The Jungle
which could only be a good thing in my
opinion there's also been a pretty big
change to the vision system basically
Ally Wards will let you know when
they're close to expiring and enemy
Wards can be pinged or attacked within
10 seconds of seeing them to create a
war timer for your team we're also
getting new communication Tools in
addition to the ones we've had for a few
years now these extra pings will include
push all in hold and bait the vision
wheel is also getting Vision cleared and
need Vision they're also adding
off-screen ping indicators so you don't
have to be looking at the exact perfect
spot to see your allies ping personally
I like the sound of these changes I
remember when everyone complained about
the original ping wheel and now it's
hard to imagine a game without it but I
do agree with the sentiment that at this
point it feels like Riot are trying to
implement just about every form of
communication tool except a proper voice
chat I just think they don't trust
league players sad which is weird
because they gave that to valerun right
off the bat and now they have all these
fancy ways of detecting toxicity so I
don't know what's going on there we're
also getting an objective voting system
so your team can in theory decide to do
an objective as a group without needing
to be spammed 50 times by one player I
say in theory there because for me this
kind of feels a little bit like wishful
thinking I think it could be one of
those features that works really well if
your team is ahead everyone's being nice
to each other politely asking their
teammates if they'd like to start an
objective sounds great but as soon as
things turn sour for a team and let's be
honest that happens 50 of the time I
don't think this feature is getting used
at all I don't think teammates that are
fighting each other are going to get
around the table for a democratic vote
unless it's to Forfeit and just move on
maybe I'm being cynical here but that's
what I think will happen we're also
going to get a whole bunch of new items
as well as the return of some old
favorites such as the Spear of shojin
and Rod of Ages god it feels like it's
been years I mean it has and of course
there's a whole bunch of champion tweaks
as well and that in a rather large messy
nutshell is the pre-season patch we did
it obviously it's out now so some of you
watching this will have already played a
bit on it does it feel weird does it
feel good let me know what you think so
far I'm probably gonna try out some
jumbling today and I can't wait to pick
my very first starter Pokemon I mean
companion jungle companion definitely no
legal issues there
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock